[Music]
thank you
stop True Crime bragging comment section
of my favorite murder episode somehow
makes its way into the show
my generation gets traumatized for
breakfast kids was it my best work I
don't know does it deserve to be [ __ ] on
creatively instead of acknowledging how
childhood memories can be inaccurate
Rick gets all defensive as if Beth just
dropped in everything wrong with
froopyland video this calendar with only
four days in the week in our collapsed a
Quantum Tesseract adding the word
Quantum to no wait adding the word
Tesseract to no that's not it either
okay got it combining two sciency words
and adding a random verb to create a
phrase that sounds like Rick did
something impressive cliche drawing a
portal on a mobile door based on the
trees alone it's pretty obvious that
Rick ripped off Dr Seuss and no one gets
away with that without a sinning dad
you're right I'm a terrible dad the
terrible dad then goes on to throw
himself from the cliff that won't kill
him rather than pushing his unsuspecting
daughter to her non-death and that would
have really sealed the terrible dad
title into place for eternity a dad
makes a toilet look like R2D2 and it
breaks the front page of Reddit
insinuating that Rick gives a Star Wars
size about the front page of Reddit
seriously this hurts really bad in that
case you think he wouldn't wait until
being taken to the nest to take out his
gun and shoot threat no people saw these
two people floating in people-sized
bubbles and stopped to take a picture
and or follow for the views of the
people they would surely Garner on
social media your place looks way less
like a crack house show doesn't clarify
if this assessment is based on
first-hand experience at a crack house
or some are making assumptions based on
TV or some [ __ ] it's actually clean like
a cocaine house Joe doesn't clarify if
this assessment is based on first-hand
experience at a cocaine house or Morty
making assumptions based on TV or some
[ __ ] I'm simply centered activated
writers make summer suddenly clumsy as
if Jerry isn't annoying enough to show
off his powers without provocation who
wants a smoothie first off no one said
yes and second anyone that does want a
smoothie would also like you to put a
little more effort into the recipe and
not just put every piece of rinded fruit
you have into a blender also summer and
Morty both just stand there and watch
Jerry not putting the top back on the
blender without screaming running or
voicing disapproval in any way
whatsoever I'm sure you noticed what she
has three of but guess what she has two
of is a thing that Jerry just said to
his children are you saying Tommy
survived here by having sex with froopy
creatures creating froopy human hybrid
Offspring and then consuming their
proteins sustaining himself with an
endless cycle of cannibalistic incest
writers suddenly realized their stories
the hair too long and complicated for
the show's 20-something minute run time
so they hand fist the episode with a
bunch of quick-witted Exposition wrapped
in a plot reveal so disgusting we feel
the need to go wash our hands during the
commercial break did you under
understand how serious crew tabulon Soul
bonding is nope and considering it
doesn't come up for the remainder of the
episode it's probably not that big of a
deal at all she's got a hotbod like
chitara and Thundercats if the
ThunderCats exist in this cartoon
Universe would they be considered
cartoons or by the standards of their
reality would they be considered live
action and if a cartoon Universe has its
own version of cartoons when those
cartoons have to be one-dimensional and
what would that even look like these are
the kind of answers I watch Rick and
Morty for and I'm not getting them after
all the time and energy I spent teaching
you two about race he ended up racist
the sin is the writers thinking Jerry
would think that he could get away with
pretending to think that he could have
possibly taught anyone anything I always
find the theater is the best way to
clarify things so we're in time there's
a fifth grade version of me watching a
performance of The Crucible that would
very much disagree you want to see the
Honey Swamp the same rank that made the
ground bouncy and the water breathable
managed to overlook the fact that a
swamp filled with honey is many orders
of magnitude more dangerous than a
regular swamp
angry and all I could do to pass the
time is hump my dog's inner monologue
somehow makes its way into the episode
leave him alone
moments after Tommy has applied his seed
this animal births a new froopy
character in unfortunately the rules of
this episode place this sin in the
category of meals being prepared too
quickly to have been made in accordance
with proper food safety measures all
right that's it I'm out of here no one
untied Rick's hands he just slipped out
of them to escape so why not do this
before watching the theatric retelling
of Tommy's cringe-worthy survival plan
Tommy's still in there ripping Muppets
and eating babies here's the thing that
Beth said in this episode look at some
of the [ __ ] you were asking me to make
you as a kid ray guns do they shoot Rays
or are they named Rey or do they
specifically shoot only people named Rey
hey these are legitimate questions for a
show that's willing to introduce a
sentient switchblade a lightning gun
that's just a fancy taser a taser shaped
like a ladybug that's just a fancy
lightning gun a pink sentient
switchblade does it being pink make it
worse then why didn't you specify the
colors of the other objects hmm Rick and
why hasn't Rick fixed his boo-boos has
it occurred to you that I asked you to
make those things because I wanted you
to spend time with me has occurred to
you that your request for these items
resulted in a father that actually made
them thereby encouraging your behavior
take that to your next counseling
session I I think you have to stab them
through the heart or something says the
guy stabbing the creature through the
head so if the alien heart is the head
then Morty should share that specific
information with his family to avoid
confusion people should eat people they
should not and that's why one percent
plus two [ __ ] makes a bunch of
[ __ ] a bunch at most this is a
clowder and you know it look I'm not an
evil person I'm just not very
imaginative but doesn't it take
imagination to create the line that your
children were responsible for the
breakup I know Jerry makes no sense but
the writing of Jerry not making sense
should make sense makes sense this
calendar with only five days in the week
we wouldn't dare play the music in the
background of this touching
father-daughter working moment mostly
because it's song about taking a shirt
and the show is trying to make us think
it's a metaphor for fatherhood they have
this t-shirt just laying around or do
they spend time making this because it's
not easy writing on t-shirts it takes a
lot of time to get the lettering right
so this feels a bit like they wasted
time on this instead of rushing to stop
the execution having more fridge
pictures of a child that you do not
prefer none of the varics show shows
this moment of distraction to attack the
warrior woman who slaughtered their kin
yesterday you just you just ended at ex
machina cliche
we're home leaving the front door wide
the
[ __ ] arnaldo's isn't closed in the
dimension where they didn't invent
daylight savings what would we do
without you find a pizza place that
doesn't close before dinner time or at
least not before the sun goes down by
the way that wasn't time travel there
were just a couple pizzas on the counter
I grabbed them Rick has to break the
fourth wall to explain something so the
internet doesn't explode with fan
theories about what the insipid detail
of Rick not waiting for pizza means in
regard to what is and is impossible
Jerry it's the Big R uh I killed that
alien that was coming after you looking
out for you buddy show thinks we would
momentarily believe that Rick did
something nice for Jerry and not see the
future joke coming from a mile away
you couldn't keep that answering machine
nobody really uses those anymore except
for exposition on TV shows anyways show
cleverly writes its way out of an
Antiquated joke by expositing its own
Exposition but still exposition
I do not want to live in Rainbow Land
and you can't make
who wants a smoothie what are you
talking about a smooth like a drink or
something listen I've been given you
because I'm Charmed and life finds a way
but it's one thing the history of
evolution has taught us it's that life
will not be contained life breaks free
it expands to new territories and it
crashes through barriers painfully maybe
even dangerously but uh oh there it is
well here's the problem right here a
mutated p-36 immunosuppression Gene that
renders them immune to all poisons
what is that smell it's poo poo with a
dash of cocoa I suppose you're wondering
how do I sustain myself I am evil
therefore I am lonely
mm-hmm
well that didn't go as planned I respect
your right to believe I pushed you when
you marooned me on that God forsaken
spit of land you forgot one very
important thing mate I'm Captain Jack
Sparrow I roared I rampaged and I got
bloody satisfaction